Speaker 1: . So yesterday I told you that
Texas Republican Senator Ted Cruz was in
New York City for the Astros Yankees game and he
was brutally booed and heckled at Yankee Stadium
more substantively. Yesterday, he appeared on
the New York City based talk show The View, and
it was completely off the rails, one of the most
bad faith interview performances I've seen in a
very long time. And I want to go over some of this
with you, because it is so emblematic of how these
folks operate in a fact, free and also completely
amoral framework. The View co-host Ana Navarro,
a lifelong Republican but an anti-Trump
Republican. She confronts Cruz and says,
How did you go from being against Trump
and him calling your wife ugly to suddenly
you support the guy? Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: Frankly, I don't know how you get
over your wife being called ugly. I don't know
how you get over those kind of calumnies against
your father. But you obviously have gotten over it
today using a very different tone. So tell us what
you're lying then, or are you lying now?
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's that's
a loaded question there.
Speaker 4: I think a lot of people
have the same question. It's a very different Ted
Cruz that we're seeing. We are. And would you not
agree that that's very different? Ted Cruz No.
Speaker 5: What I would say is this in 2016 we
had a primary where Donald Trump and I beat the
living crap out of each other. I'll tell you,
Heidi laughed when he said that. My father
laughed. By the way, my dad didn't just kill
Kennedy. He's got Jimmy Hoffa.
Speaker 1: Ted, it was so funny
when Donald Trump called me ugly.
Speaker 4: It was it's so funny.
Speaker 1: It's like
watching, you know, a rom com.
Speaker 5: Buried in the backyard. It was idiotic.
And we went after each other. And at
the end of the day, he won. And I had
a decision to make in November of 2016.
Speaker 1: Yes. Am I going to stand on
principles and maybe be on the outs
with the president? Or do I want to
start sucking up to keep access to power?
Speaker 5: He'd been elected president and I
got a responsibility to represent 30 million
Texans. I could've decided my feelings are
hurt. I'm going to take the ball and go home and
not do my job. But if I was prepared to do that,
I better be prepared to resign from my job
because I have a responsibility. So what I did is,
is I went and said, listen, we have an opportunity
to make a difference for this country and I want
to roll up my sleeves and lead the fight to
actually deliver on promises. We were talking a
minute ago about the incredible booming economy.
We saw 7 million people get off of food stamps.
Speaker 1: 7 million people. And food stamps
does not actually address how and why Ted Cruz
got in line with Trump. And remember that if
everybody laughed about Trump calling Heidi Cruz
ugly back in 2016, why was it that in the
immediate aftermath, Ted Cruz referred to Trump
as a sniveling coward because of those comments
and said, Leave Heidi the hell alone? If everybody
laughed and had a good time after that, why did
he do it? Ana Navarro also confronts Ted Cruz
with some of the specific things he said about.
Speaker 4: Trump was what you said about him back
in 2016 during the campaign. Let's take a look.
Speaker 5: I'm not to tell you what I really
think of Donald Trump. This
man is a pathological liar.
True, he doesn't know the difference between
truth and lies. He lies. Practically every word
that comes out of his mouth. The man is utterly
amoral if morality does not exist for him. True?
Speaker 4: Yeah. So I have to ask you,
because, you know, I'm married to a Cuban
man. I frankly don't know how you get over
your wife being called ugly. I don't know
how you get over those kind of calumny.
Speaker 1: Okay. So then they go into the
part that we already saw. Another interesting
moment during this was that Ted Cruz just could
not be in New York City and not get heckled.
Climate activists interrupted the interview.
And then Whoopi Goldberg says, let us do
our job. And it just gets completely crazy.
Speaker 5: It's very simple. If you look at
inflation, the Nobel laureate economist Milton
Friedman explained In the United States,
inflation has one cause and one cause
of. Inflation in the United States has one
cars and one cars. And that is when the federal
government spends too much money.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Speaker 5: We have seen trillions and trillions
of dollars spent by Joe Biden, the Democrats,
just last year. Last year, the federal government
took in $4 trillion in lost money. In history
we've ever taken in. And the problem is, we
spent nearly $7 trillion. And that's what we do.
Speaker 4: There is money to cover of Time.
Ladies, ladies. Excuse us. Let us do our job. Let
us do our job. We hear what you have to say.
Unidentified: And you got to go. You
gotta let us do our job.
Speaker 1:
All right, so then they start
to get kicked out, but somehow,
then they get more energy, and then
they're back, and then they end up
having to mute everything and cut to commercial.
Speaker 5: The biggest reason people at home are
saying, okay, is my life better today than it was
two years ago? And I think for the vast majority
of Americans, the answer is no. He died.
Speaker 1:
All right. So total guests on The View. ABC
spokesperson put out a statement saying that
three people in the audience interrupted
the view and they were escorted out. These
interviews are not going particularly well
for Ted Cruz. But I have to tell you what,
if you see this through the eyes of right
wingers and we're going to see things through
the eyes of right wingers in a moment, you see
a guy whose speech they are trying to suppress
and that it is unhinged people doing it. So,
you know, you and I know that this guy is the
lowest of the low, truly. But understand
that the right wingers see this and they
go look at those liberals. They don't want to
let him speak and suppressing speech. And next,
we are going to look exactly at what is going
on in the minds of some of these people.